Boston Province and the surrounding New
England areas we have a major alert for
you and we ain't talking about the snow
no we're talking about a low ticket
warning come out and see the live show
baby yeah guys it's a great way to
introduce your friends to the show grab
the crew grab the home he's grabbed the
bozos come out uh there's still some
tickets left for December 6th in
Providence at the second show out of the
The Late Show in Boston has a few
tickets left get them now let's party do
it welcome to another exciting edition
of are you garbage the show where you
find out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
they're good to be classy after just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave only coming at you on a beautiful
day we're down here at antuti's basement
she's upstairs putting up the Christmas
decorations okay that she stole from the
neighbor's house all right good for her
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me God damn it one of these days
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman he is not to
be trifled with in the Board Room or the
bedroom gang give it up for KJ it's
Kevin James Ryan let's go hey gang
what's up thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are over a hundred
thousand over there you go waiting on my
plaque baby melt that thing down let's
go and then obviously the greatest
goddamn website of all [ __ ]
times
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it the [ __ ] out all that money
love that money how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones and twos crosses the t's
and dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
McMuffin Toby McMullen everybody what's
up dudes what's up buddy we gotta mind
our p's and q's on this one this broad's
got all the LA back in her eyes
got a real high society lady
what are you talking about this is gonna
be a cakewalk this is an opening Let's
Go Gang we couldn't be more excited I
mean could not be more excited to have
our incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time she is a
very funny stand-up comedian actor and
podcaster you may have seen her in but
not limited to you got apartment nine
you got getting Doug with high you got
pop pie life fails Tales from the trip
you got shank you have lights out with
David Spade you have had to do [ __ ] with
Guido gagoots which I love that show and
you also have The Joe Rogan Experience
and she is the host of the shank podcast
and the co-host of this [ __ ] podcast
but the big question was mine today is
she garbage let's go real quick known
associates Kim cogdan trash of the South
Florida Coggins
and then she is also a very close
associate with a young man by the name
of Josh Potter who also refers to
himself as the roach yeah so this is
what you call a slam dunk gang but give
it up for Sarah wine shank everybody
let's go let's go little L.A star power
in here thanks for coming that's what
I'm talking about oh my God I'm so
excited to be here you guys there's not
a chance in hell you can roll with those
with Kim and Potter
and have somewhat of any class and you
gotta be trash
Guilty By Association yeah it's like
Rico charges you get one you get them
all they all go there yeah those are two
literally of my best best friends yeah
that's crazy yeah plus Potter kept going
to you for the shrooms at skank Fest so
I was like yeah that's true this kid's
in deep I'll pay it out
um shift the backstory what's the back
story where are you from are you from
L.A I'm from L.A but I'm from the valley
yes so the Valley's you know
so that is the trash here the people on
angle like in L.A it's like ooh you're
from the valley right yeah yeah is it an
actual Valley can I ask that yeah it's
on the other side of the mountain or
something yeah it's just if you are in
West Hollywood you just would drive
through Laurel Canyon and then you'd
come to the trash or the trashier side
that's where it is remember they went to
the van and drama's like get me out of
here we're in the valley I think over
the valley bro yeah uh what'd your
parents do give us the whole scoop okay
my dad's a lawyer all right ambulance
Chaser what is it what kind of lawyer
Construction
[Laughter]
your dad's a lawyer okay my mom does his
bookkeeping okay all right all right
sounds like my family so you're trash
the office is in the garage for sure
okay your dad's a lawyer and you're so
they always work together growing when
you're growing up yeah all right did he
do good he did good yeah he did good as
well yeah okay brothers and sisters I
have a younger sister okay all right how
far apart are you guys uh she's three
years younger than me she's three years
younger was it public school private
school private Catholic school
why that Radar's off here the public
school's real bad and that's it was that
or was it a religious thing no my dad's
a Jew my mom's catholic they're like
Catholic school is cheaper okay
send her to the all girls catholic
school keep it moving I like it I
respect it yeah because the private the
regular private school that's not
religious is very expensive sure right
right right I could see what's the name
of that school I went to this all girls
high school called Louisville Louisville
school after Kentucky
they're like they're like 48th it's not
St Louisville or anything like that just
Louisville
wait so it's just called she's also
trash though is it yeah yeah that is it
Louisville's School for Girls or
something like that Louisville
what was the name of the mascot
Louisiana it was a Royals
is that a bird maybe the Royals yeah
it's a bird it's a bird I don't know
what was like the Kansas City Royals yes
that's what I would think
but your dad did good so your mom
basically didn't work and did he did he
do uh
was the office in the home or did he
have an office he had an office he got
up and went to work every day yes what'd
your mom do my mom when we were little
she stayed home as a stay-at-home mom
and then when we got older she started
doing his book start doing his books
yeah about how many people work under
him at the law office
um it's just he just has a small part um
is the main guy right just him and then
he has
his uh secretary okay all right
it's got real better calls yeah
does Bill Burr work okay
um what kind of what kind of house did
you grow up in was it like a single
family home Standalone house or an
apartment condo town it's a nice house
it's like a four bedroom home pretty
good my grandpa built it really like he
was the construction guy yeah that's how
my dad got into doing construction
because my grandpa was in construction
okay it's your dad's side yeah right
okay so your grandfather your
grandfather did well in construction was
the rest of your family around their
cousins and stuff like that uh my
cousins yikes for sure for sure trash
how many brothers and sisters selling
everybody out I don't talk to them well
once they start trolling You on YouTube
you can drag them on any podcast all
right here we go all right
this is your dad's side of the family
yeah so you guys aren't close no okay
all right all right fair enough how
about the mob side of the family big
family small family well both of them
have very small families are they both
from L.A County as well my mom's from
Queens your mom's from Queens my mom's
from Astoria really yeah I live in
Astoria shout out to it oh of course
maybe you can meet a lawyer one day
settle down in California start keeping
his books I like it let's go where did
they meet they met okay so my this is
this is gonna be maybe trashy founding
sure okay which is typically trashy okay
yeah it's real classy just sounds trash
so my okay I'm trying to figure out how
to explain this in a way that makes
sense so it doesn't sound like we're in
breath okay
guys I swear to God she's not they're
not cousins okay so uh my mom
my mom my mom's Aunt moved to LA and got
married okay when she came to LA to
visit her aunt okay she met her aunt's
new husband's son that's my dad
that's yeah that's inbred that's not in
bread because it's different sides of
the family but you're saying by law it's
still taboo either way but still
so your aunt married somebody who
already had kids from a previous
marriage yes
and then who's my grandpa who's your
grandpa
aunt's husband
okay so my aunt's husband yeah is my
grandpa because wait no yeah that's not
right
I would be trolling you too if I was one
of you wait a minute different sides of
the family your mom's Aunt I need a tree
okay so my mom
grew up in New York and her aunt grew up
in New York her aunt moves to L.A meets
a dude all right hold on let's just give
them fake names just so I can so Aunt
Trish Aunt Trish moves to that'd be
crazy if I guessed it I'm sorry who is
your mom who is your mom's sister my
it's my mom's Aunt your mom yeah okay so
you're a great aunt so Aunt Trish your
mom's Aunt Trish moves out to California
meets Steve right Steve has
two kids two kids Bill and Nancy uh-huh
Bill and your mom me me get married
so they're technically step cousins if a
trade for New York leaves the same time
from LA are you inbred yeah it's
Louisville's really starting to make
sense now sweet hold on so that guy is
your grandfather in the sense of he's
your step grandfather really he's my
grandfather because he's my dad's dad
right your mom's your mom's uncle by
marriage is your dad's dad yes okay what
does that make the ant trashy she's she
is my great aunt but then also in some
ways my grandma
you're way too cool about that
Grandma I still can't really get my head
around I got it I'm there and it's not a
good place so don't don't meet us down
here save yourself
your mom I can wrap this up like your
mom married your aunts
husband's kid from a previous marriage
yes so how does that make him your
grandfather though
oh yeah that is that his yeah
your aunt married your grandfather oh
man
yes and you're not even from the south
yeah yeah yeah like your own rules
okay all right okay okay well you're
down on the count already I started out
strong but unless one of them's a queen
it's gonna be tough to bounce back for
himself man how did they explain when
did they explain that to you as a kid
they explained it to me and they said
it's gonna seem confusing
they were right what are you what are
you what are you two years old Sarah sit
down and put on a pot of coffee what do
your parents say what do your mom and
dad think about it whatever it is they
think it normal because yeah okay it's
from a previous marriage there is no
blood yeah there's no blood it's from a
previous marriage I don't know because
my grandpa was married three times this
was his last wife okay
okay yeah okay that's kind of like what
happened in Clueless right I guess that
was his Stepbrother
didn't she
she got together with Paul ruddle run
was a neighbor what are you talking
about it was the son of her pre his the
previous stepmom but he the dad uh the
dad wasn't Paul Rudd's Dad yes it would
be stepson right yeah they were step
siblings that's where those videos are
coming from on my computer that's where
it all started I don't know he had a lot
of cash and clueless though hmm all
right yeah this is just this whole
inbred things destroyed to me that is a
bombshell that might be a first that
might be a first I love the way you guys
are processing this information it's
funny
because I don't identify as being inbred
table with you guys I have a head maybe
this is why I'm a comedian yeah I don't
identify with being in red her tooth
just falls out as she said
do does your uh I was gonna ask the last
time you went to a flea market you were
[ __ ] in it now does your mom and your
dad still in the same house you grew up
in yes okay
um
so without giving too much away is it a
street is it a road is it an Avenue it's
an Avenue it's an Avenue okay that's not
bad cul-de-sac involved anywhere no cold
no cul-de-sac
um four bedroom house
do you have a garage yep did you have a
refrigerator in the garage yep what was
in there lots of sodas okay lots of like
Diet Cokes Dr Brown's soda black cherry
that's a little bit of cash
what was the pool situation you guys
have a pool we added a pool later above
ground or in-ground in ground classy any
hot tub action on that we have a hot tub
connected
stone work all right waterfall involved
yeah there's a waterfall damn really can
I come over what's happening yeah I
apologize
and they kept all the money in the
family
that's how you protect a fortune okay I
watched the crown I know what's going on
okay that's nice
okay all right I like how you just said
you were inbred and then you're like I
got a hot tub we're like
forget about all that other stuff what
about
um what was the grocery store situation
growing up where would your mom shop
Gelson's that's pretty clean it's all
right that's okay all right but
sometimes we go sometimes Ralphs
and then if for paper towels and stuff
Smart and Final because it's cheaper
it's cheaper Smart and Final yeah
I have a feeling they have a no refund
that's smart and final smart and get out
yeah wow is that a grocery store as well
or is that more like no that's pretty
trashy Smart and Final well if anybody
doesn't know the LA area Gelson's and
um Rouse they're both they're they're
Gelson's way nicer than Ralph I know but
even even Ralph's is not bad yeah Smart
and Final is a chain of warehouse
warehouse style food and supply stores
based in Commerce California supply
store yeah
okay all right
um what was the name of the pizza place
you guys went to Growing Up
um I'm eat no
no Mulberry Street Mulberry Street Pizza
that sounds pretty good
man sounds all right welcome in both
worlds any pets growing up
yes we had a cat Okay and then a dog
standard not at the same time no
and a few goldfish
rest in peace from carnivals yeah
about live too long
they live like two weeks no this
Carnival goldfish lived for about eight
years no way yes
your parents were replacing it when it
died I swear to [ __ ] God it was a
carnival goldfish and it lived for about
eight years that's impossible I swear to
God it was one of the strong ones
oh my God no way yes that's impossible
that would that would be the Guinness
Book of World Records well then maybe we
made it
um what's your sister do now my sister
works for a comp a tech company okay
very nice uh did you go to college yes
where'd you go to school at Chapman
University in Orange County Chapman
University okay not familiar but it
sounds like a nice establishment I was
very [ __ ] boring where else did you
apply to I applied a lot of places I
applied to Emerson didn't get it in okay
I applied to I don't even know where
else LMU didn't get in USC UCLA I didn't
get I didn't even apply to USC or UCLA
because
yeah exactly right now those essays I
barely got into Chapman okay they have a
58 acceptance rate
that's more than [ __ ] Chi Institute
holy [ __ ] I heard the rise 48.
did you play any sports growing up uh
soccer that was never good okay but I
had heart
okay I thought she was gonna say I had
heart problems
what were the family vacations what's
your grandma in about that family
vacations okay one time we rented an RV
oh boy and are we doing this at like you
said so you're not too close to your
extended family so in these situations
the holidays vacations it's just it's
just it's just the four of us just the
four years yeah okay the four of us we
rented an RV one time we drove up the
California coast that was fun that seems
nice it's not bad yeah out who drove
your mom or your dad yeah
sounds nice a lot of very
very close there's nothing very far
go to Disneyland ever go to Disney World
no never went to Disney World Disneyland
a lot okay Disneyland a lot what's a lot
I mean like once a year yeah once a year
okay would you say you're Disney people
look at your parents big in the Disney
no but I hate to say this out loud I
like Disney that's okay this is all
right I live close to Disneyland in
college and I had a season pass I ride a
ride and then go to class really yeah
yeah yeah you go to Disneyland on your
lunch break yeah that's wild yeah okay
season pass but like okay Space Mountain
what's uh what's the season pass set you
back over there at Disney I mean now
it's probably way more but then it was
awesome no it was closer to 200. oh 200
bucks yeah oh all right okay that's more
bang for your butt you're just that's
smart money right there yeah okay let's
talk about them true Classics baby true
classic let's talk about the best
T-shirt in the business I got one on
right now not even lion yeah holiday
season's coming up you want to have a
little milk and cookies you want to dig
in to a couple of snacks go ahead
because true Classics has you covered
because here's the juice here's the
turkey they make them t-shirts for guys
with a certain body type when you get a
regular t-shirt true classic cut for a
portly fella cut for the big boys man
they keep the sleeves a little bit lower
I feel like Ellie spreads I feel like
next college football player when you
put one on dude I slide it but trim I
slide one of those things on man you
feel like Superman you feel like a
million bucks so gang do yourself a
favor you're over in a true classic pick
yourself up the greatest t-shirt ever
yeah they got polos workout shirts boxer
briefs the whole nine yards they got
these sizes all the way up to Triple XL
and right now you get 25 off a true
classic.com garbage free shipping
included on purchases over a hundred
bucks look at that that's 25 off true
25.25 sorry 25 off at trueclassic.com
garbage Santa won't be the only one
slaying thanks to True classes get some
get some tail with true classes that's
an option talking about Kip how about
that manscape ah manscape talk about
something you can easily slide in the
stocking this year do yourself a favor
ladies get your guys straightened out
get him to manscape 4.0 plus they got
the Platinum package you can set
yourself up with let them trim the
hedges down there you know what I mean
guys they got it all the police the big
man said Platinum Platinum package 4.0
they got the lawnmower body trimmer I
got the weed whacker and those in here
hair trimming or waterproof you can
shave anywhere underwater clean your
balls fellas guys what are we doing run
a tight ship yeah it's [ __ ] 2022
nobody wants to be going down on you
come up with a fur ball you know what I
mean we're all friends here if you had a
booger we would tell you have a booger
in your nose your nuts stink yeah so
clean them up trim the hedges tighten up
the bush freshen it up they also got a
premium Ultra Premium body wash Ultra
Premium two in one shampoo and
conditioner and Ultra Premium deodorant
check it out right now you get 20 plus
20 off plus free shipping with code
garbage at manscape.com that's 20 and
off plus free shipping with code garbage
at man's manscape.com manscaped get your
jingle balls ready for the holidays what
about the injuries as a kid break
anything crack my head open
you don't say
who says it like that yeah crack my head
up Vietnam that stuff like that
how'd you crack your head open on a step
okay it was a uh like a marble step I
went like this my mom put a gate up and
she went upstairs and I went to go get
her and I just fell
yeah huh pretty good
not bad all in construction built the
house you get good deals stitches
stitches yeah any did you did you
actually crack your skull at all no just
some stitches just some stitches okay
did you uh drink milk with dinner when
you were growing up no okay we were my
mom doesn't like milk so I didn't drink
milk no milk what would you drink when
you sat down at dinner uh water orange
juice maybe a black cherry Dr Brown sure
okay is it orange juice
[Laughter]
that's crazier than milk
get a nice tea lady
okay uh ever arrested as a kid no never
arrested as an adult no okay okay pulled
over sure I've gone through DUI things
had to walk on a line before but never
arrested nice there you go knock on wood
but Pennies on your tongue may say is
that true no I don't know uh the
holidays your dad's Jewish your mom was
Catholic uh-huh uh what did you guys
celebrate Christmas you did Christmas
did you do anything
with the Jews no not really no sometimes
there'd be a dreidel or two sure maybe
Hanukkah Harry or something yeah what
about about Mitzvah no no but Mitzvah
sweet 16 yes really what was that
looking like it was just at a nice it
was at this French restaurant in the
valley okay it was small who how many
people like friends or just friends
friends it was probably under 20 people
okay do you remember what the hall was
on that what you what you made Cash Wise
money you got oh did you get any big
gifts
no I didn't get anything like that I
didn't get bot Mitzvah level Cash ever
um there's nothing better than it I know
maybe I should get one yeah
so much money I know yeah I know
um no I didn't get lot of money you got
a bunch of jewelry I got some jewelry
yeah okay for a reasonably priced
jewelry like a 200 bracelet nothing
nothing crazy yeah no drip no diamonds
no no real ice yeah no ice when did you
get your first job
uh when I was 15. nice and what was that
Abercrombie oh okay you worked retail
yeah not bad I know yeah and then I
worked at Saddle Ranch what's that is
that right is that right next to the
store yes when I was 19 I worked there
it's this Western Dive Bar Steakhouse
right Chop House and they we've walked
by any other Rider you can ride the bull
there okay I would sell bull rides
that's what you did yeah you weren't a
waiter no it was the hostess slash bull
ride saleswoman what does a bull ride
saleswoman do day to day give me a ride
and what's the insurance package like on
something like that okay well first of
all I had to say they also it was all
about upselling at Saddle Ranch all
sales is yeah of course they would give
me certain phrases that I'd have to say
so I would seat people and then I'd say
you should try the cobbler it's like the
reason I work here and then I walk away
even though I never had the cobbler ones
um
um and then yeah with temple rides
people I'd be like what's up you guys
having fun you want to get on the ball
come to yeah come over here I'll send
you did you get a commission or anything
uh no but there's a tip thing and uh the
girls who sold the bull rides we would
make a lot I'd make a good amount of
money I did this job for the summer was
it like a flirty thing would you find
guys hey what's up and they try to
impress the cute girl yeah yeah yeah I
would have been on that bullet
yeah squeeze a bicep you're up there
oh I got tased one time to impress a
girl you were uh I did a true story no
okay yeah were you living at your
parents while you were doing this yes
because it was the summer in between
college and you graduated yeah I
graduated what was the major
Communications okay all right uh what
was the poster situation in the room as
a kid a poster situation poster any
posters on the wall
had any posters no really we're poster
free the wine tanks were poster free
okay what was on the walls in your
bedroom as a kid there was a border
around you know how is it in the middle
of the room or the top the top was it
wood like crown molding there was crown
molding but underneath that my mom put
up this [ __ ] weird border and it was
all these kids and they were had um like
bicycles and wagons and I wonder how old
were you when she put it up when you
were when I was a baby yeah and then I
would have nightmares that those people
came alive and were trying to kill me
[Laughter]
that's pretty classy though so you have
no posters on the wall
um as a kid was your bed a single bed or
a double bed or a queen or would you
have a queen yeah you had a queen bed
yes as a kid yes rich kid in a valley
yeah she's a rich kid
growing up there did you at any point as
a kid try to impersonate a celebrity
like tell someone you were someone's kid
to get into a restaurant or anything
like that no you ever rob anything from
Paris Hilton's house no but I I'm
friends with someone who did that
documentary yes I'm friends with her
Alexis
they want a shopping spree though oh
yeah wow yeah because they were Valley
kids yeah as a kid in high school did
you ever go to any crazy Hollywood
parties I would go to clubs all the time
before I started doing stand-up when I
was probably around 18 19 20 like that
whole period I would be out I'd be out
I'd see Lindsay Lohan I'd be like Oh I'm
a part of this yeah we're in the same
place in the vicinity of uh yeah it
would be Nicole Richie Lindsay Lohan
those types of things in different on
different days there was different clubs
right gotcha and then I'm like I need
something else to live for besides dude
like a promote or somebody you text hey
we're here yeah type thing yeah okay all
right wow okay what was your first
concert
uh Kenny Loggins in Vegas
yeah I hang out with Paris Hilton and
Lindsay Lohan Kenny Loggins you weren't
your parents I was with my parents yeah
okay you guys were in Vegas we're in
Vegas on a vacation on a vacation yeah
drive there fly there we flew okay
that's the classier how old were you
when you went probably around 10 10 they
took you to Las Vegas on a family
vacation for like hey let's go for the
weekend no we went on a vacation but
like to Vegas now they say it out loud
it's pretty weird did you stay in a
hotel yeah we stayed in Mandalay Bay
Also let's put a pin in that real quick
yeah you just recently went on a
timeshare pitch oh yeah no that's coming
up I I got you haven't gone yet no it's
coming up in January
explain this okay so after skank Fest my
good friend Josh Potter gives me a
little bit of Xanax before my flight
okay
I'm not I'm at the Golden Nugget minding
my own business waiting for my waiting
for myself that's how it always starts
sister doesn't it I'm at the Golden
Nugget might do my own business
[ __ ] Mr Papa Georgio over here
all right I'm minding my own business
waiting for a latte to come out it comes
out and in the in between time this guy
who's just posted up over here comes
across and goes can I interest you in a
luxury VIP vacation and at this you're
sold I am so [ __ ] tired from skank
Fest and New York and all of it that I'm
like a vacation and he goes yeah what
are you here for go Comedy Festival he's
like oh I got a VIP thing because you're
here with the Comedy Festival but his
pitch was so [ __ ] good and I was like
whatever he's just some guy ride sales
just some guy at the bar he's some guy
who has a little desk set up inside the
Golden Nugget next to the Starbucks
where I'm waiting for my drink is that
where we stayed too
probably yes it was okay I know exactly
what you're talking about the Starbucks
yes which I don't think I did I got
Bamboozled outside the Chick-fil-A slash
Starbucks
and I don't think that Chick-fil-A was
serving Chick-fil-A chicken because it
smelled way different
or something he kept saying that every
time
all right so you see you have to go so
how did he close you
he said for 199 I said I'm listening for
199 bucks he said 199 you got a 394 day
vacation I said I could use a vacation
I'm gonna grab my latte I'll be right
over here all where would you have to go
for the pitch so I'm going to Sedona
baby because he had to go back to Vegas
no sedona's in Arizona well you have to
go to Arizona to hear the pitch oh I'm
going on vacation and they give you the
vacation for 200 but then on the third
day of the vacation you're actually
gonna block you well cause I want the
vacation
are you sure you're not going to get
kidnapped or anything like that I had a
red vest Henry he was authorized
uh yeah so I'm going on this vacation
they're gonna give me a 120 minute
presentation did you did you already
like pay for it you put your credit card
I paid for the 199 vacation but I
haven't committed to the timeshare when
I get there from what I hear it's going
to be bad yeah should I not go should I
just take the loss I think I should
definitely film it 100 Vlogs no I know
wait did they pay for your flight too no
I should have to pay for your own flight
yeah what is Sedona I'm not familiar
it's in Arizona it's like uh a lot of
hippies go there okay there's a whole
there's energy vortexes in Sedona and
because I'm kind of a hippie too like
the part of La I live in is a hippie
okay okay yeah okay so I'm there to get
my chakras get get everything lined up
get it all lined up and then they're
gonna pitch you a timeshare in is it in
that area of the time share I don't know
how what's gonna happen they're gonna
lock me in a room for 120 minutes but I
know it's bad because they are giving me
a hundred and fifty dollar Visa gift
card
and they can't be good if they're giving
me 150 gift card but listen I'm going
for the 150 gift card sweetie and for
that point you're only in for 40 bucks
or whatever yeah you're definitely
walking out of there with a [ __ ]
timeshare yeah you guys laugh now but
when you're when you're hanging out of
my time
pretty nice hand fat boy huh I get this
two weeks every nine years
wild oh God
it's funny watching you guys I've never
had somebody so confidently say the wild
ass [ __ ] things you say I've never heard
anybody that got suckered into something
like that in the lobby of a hotel a week
ago like this wasn't even like
this was literally I was just out of
college I had no something yeah I don't
know I didn't know what time you'd know
what time shares are don't you no okay
okay I didn't grow up around timeshare
energy all right you're gonna find out
I'm not 100 what they are either I know
it's a rip-off yeah and then you sign
you to a long-term dealer so they sign
you up it's like hey if you give me hold
on a second just to be don't do it I'm
not doing it but I'm scared to go there
after they lock me in the room I don't
know what's gonna happen I think they
might starve me brainwashed they're
gonna stop you at a phoenix shipping
container and they're just City to San
Juan
you guys should I not go I want the
vacation what's the name of the company
Hilton
wait Hilton is the ship it all comes
back diamonds Hilton Diamond Resorts
Hilton timeshare okay huh sounds above
board stop don't do it don't do it I'm
not doing it all right but I want the
three-day vacation sure but at what cost
at this point I probably could have just
booked her normal vacation yeah Mama for
sure I would say if you get there as
long as you're allowed to like pick your
own room like not like it's not like if
you get there and they already have a
room key for you at the hotel I would
probably get the [ __ ] out of there
then I'm already there right what do you
mean I mean there but you don't bringing
Kim with me I think it's all going to be
up on Kim's going Kim's will choke out
yeah that's what I'm saying that's why
yeah cause I'm the idiot I bring camera
in a bodyguard my muscles
yeah don't bring Potter he's talking
about
Josh Potter was so [ __ ] up I just
bought a car wash
but stuff like I was getting because he
came up to me and he could get Jeff
Potter got this close to my face he goes
Kevin is that you I go you better
[ __ ] open to me it'd be real weird if
it wasn't
shout out I love him all right let's
[ __ ] she's Bamboozled on us here
um
were you a Crystal Light family growing
up no no Crystal Light I wish doc Browns
is pretty nice
although your dad being Jewish
kind of cancels it out a little bit it's
like part of the culture a little bit
yeah it's true did he have the celery
one by any chance huh okay
anything in your apartment your house
right now that says live laugh love no
anything in your parents house that says
live life no okay what was the
um lunch situation uh in school as a kid
was your mom making lunch she made it it
was wheat bread a lot of wheat bread
happening a wheat bread in the 90s it
was wild I just wanted it was all right
I would beg I would say please just get
my white bread and bologna so I could
fit in and then she gave it to me one
time I was like this is [ __ ]
disgusting that strogan wheat bread was
all right
what was on the sandwich turkey mayo
tomato lettuce
it's pretty that's all right that's all
right what was the chip situation
goldfish should give you goldfish
and the drink the drink I don't I feel
like she dropped the ball a little bit
on the drink I don't remember ever
having good drinks I think just water
Pepperidge Farms I mean hey you could
she could give you a [ __ ] Anchovies
and peppered form crackers that's all
right but then she gave me this one
thing that I think about makes me sick
because she gave it to me so [ __ ]
much those Nature Valley granola bars I
love those I hated I [ __ ] we only got
the apples and cinnamon ones though the
green one oh the peanut butter ones were
banging this one was honey it was the
honey kind and it was too ugh yeah as a
kid you don't want that to be in there
eating [ __ ] Oreos make with the Kudos
let's go yeah we're eating like a badger
what about breakfast what would they
give you for breakfast at the house uh
waffles you'd have waffles Eggos wheat
waffles
nutrigrain waffles I want to say sounds
like a shoe box yeah those things
Shredded Wheat Shredded Wheat Raisin
Bran not a lot of sweets in the house no
but then I go over to my friends and
just binge out of course you did it you
got to get in somewhere you know Pop
Tarts in the house only if only on
special occasions what would be a
special occasion to roll out the pot if
we begged can we please have Pop Tarts
and not frosted really just the regular
strawberry poor kid I know those
unfrosted Pop-Tarts sucks I know we got
the off-brand one called toastums they
were brutal we were a big Pop-Tart
family or my dad's house uh how old were
you when you got your passport first
time you left the country not till
College okay where'd you go Italy Italy
family vacation or just with the friends
I went to go do to an art history class
oh that's nice you stayed over there for
a little while for three weeks that's
all right what part of Italy I did
Florence Venice and Rome there you go
Toscano very nice okay it's pretty
classy any beekeepers in the family no
any musicians in the family well no
Sarah well one time my my cousin tried
to record a country song
um
and I don't know where it is or even how
to find it but I do know that at one
point she was like I'm recording a
country song
that's what I was looking for a dewy
Valley cousin
it's like [ __ ] you're from Calabasas
what's happening okay uh anyone in your
family have a breathalyzer in their car
no ever crash a golf cart no ever crash
someone else's car my dad's you crashed
your dad's car what age uh 16 I was
driving it to school I reversed it into
a basketball or basketball hoop you got
a basketball hoop in the driveway yeah
huh
who was playing basketball yeah for for
like a couple months was it a movable
one or was it was it concrete it was
Concrete in the ground nice sounds
pretty good what kind of car was it that
your dad was driving at the time it was
an old uh 3 Series BMW but he had it for
a really long time it was the same car
that I he drove me home from the
hospital in is the car that I crashed
okay did I [ __ ] like this guy it was
all right that sounds all right but uh
what's he whipping now
um
I think an Infinity okay SUV or sedan
SUV all right what's your mom drive a
BMW
okay what are you whipping now a Toyota
Prius nice okay what year
20 oh no 2019. very nice okay all right
you got the timeshare
um what's the last book you read a
self-help book okay
um how long ago was it I just keep
reading the South the same self-help
once
I'm not improving at all
um it was a while ago okay
established titles Lords and Ladies
hello yep I'm your host H Foley I'm a
land holder in Scotland oh you don't say
yeah and you could be two gang with
established titles you could buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land and you yourself can be called a
lord or a lady it's a good time it's fun
makes an absolutely fantastic gift do
yourself a favor get over there to
established titles yeah baby the first
200 people purchasing a title pack using
our link will effectively effectively be
next to our plots within a few minutes
of walking baby we can build our garbage
Kingdom that's an Empire right now let's
be neighbors take over Europe do what we
gotta do do a little pillaging uh it
makes a great last minute gift for your
loved ones they even have couple packs
that come with adjoining plots a plan
that's cool oh look at that uh it makes
a great last minute gift like I said
established titles is running a Black
Friday sale plus if you use the code
garbage you get an additional 10 percent
off go to establish titles.com to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel do it do it kid let's talk about
ladder baby
let's get down to the nitty gritty you
don't want to leave the fam holding the
bag do yourself a favor do the family
don't screw them over this holiday
you've been doing that your whole life
you're a deadbeat everybody knows it
don't screw them over cut your lawn for
God's sakes call your parents pull your
pants up and do yourself a favor and go
over and get yourself a little term life
insurance
send me yourself a favor 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for three million I don't like
needles I get woozy
no hidden fees you can cancel only time
you get a full refund if you change your
mind in the first 30 days because
they're good people over there their
policies are issued by insurers with
long proven histories of paying claims
are rated A and A Plus by am's best I've
been on record I don't know what that is
but it sounds good they know what
they're doing so go to ladderlife.com
today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage one more
time write it down ladderlife.com
garbage now back to that show boys and
girls back to the show do you have a
go-to karaoke song no I don't like
karaoke no I'm not I'm not a good singer
if I was a good singer I'd [ __ ] Love
karaoke and I want to be doing stand-ups
they make your own country song yeah
okay
do you know either the following dance
moves do you know the Macarena or the
Electric Slide maybe the Macarena and I
don't know if I know it exactly I know
the Macarena you do I was always so
jealous when I was getting Macarena
let's go baby
all right
um have you ever run to George Foreman
Grill no uh do you like vanilla Coke
as a kid I liked finale I love it I
haven't had it in years I love it the
diner I worked on as a kid they had
vanilla syrup and you could make your
own that's a little different I went
real heavy hand soft tastes like you
were drinking a candle it sucked
uh have you ever gone to a wax museum on
family vacation no any old-timey photos
no no have you ever made your own jello
shots yes
College college I'll give you that get a
pass were you in a sorority in college
no
uh do you go to the dentist on regularly
I just went to the dentist
this time in four years four years and
they were not happy with sure sure they
really shamed me floss every day yes
yeah every day yeah I floss every day
that's not bad what's the deodorant
situation what are you using Dove use
Dove should I use not bad
toothpaste Crest really whitening yeah
huh interesting have you ever do you
ever work making money trimming weed no
I'm done in La Vibe but also I've made
money like standing in front of weed
selling weed being like hey buy this
flower at like uh just a lot of cannabis
random like cannabis jobs of hey we need
you to come do this marketing job for
cannabis company stuff like that okay
through Instagram have you ever been a
burning man no Coachella yes you've been
to Coachella I've been to go tell us
several times okay yeah that's not a
cheap ticket
so you're one of those kids you went
with all your friends in college yeah
that's a couple jihads right there who's
floating the bill for that the old man
no I babysat and use the money from
babysitting okay Coachella all right
if I went to your house right now and
asked for water what would you give me
uh probably
like a mason jar filled out of the sink
yeah sink not out of the sink I would
pour you it from a jug from my fridge
because you can't eat drink the tap
water in L.A but The Jug would be like a
plastic jug yeah a plastic jug oh okay
and then I'd pour that into the Mason
jar for you no Brita filter no Brita
filter huh have you ever had a ring back
tone like when you call like if I were
to call you to play and play a song back
it was Aerosmith oh my God
crying is that the name
oh my God all right oh God some guy
calling you to break up with you like
how did you know oh
it's also too that was for one person
you're like you're gonna hear this
you'll hear this Trevor
[Applause]
[Music]
when I haven't thought about that in
years yeah get in there you guys I know
we really lift up the lift up turn the
stones yeah growing up did you keep the
butter on the counter in the
refrigerator fridge kept it in the
fridge what about the ketchup was that
in the refrigerator yes and the syrup
Pantry okay it checks out
um do you steal now no nothing like grab
a candy bar I just steal a salad
actually not that long ago more steel
airport and you're also a liar
from the airport no it wasn't from the
airport I was in this salad place okay
so listen money was a little tight this
day so there I am minding my own
business
it's all back at the nuggets at the
salad place no so sometimes I order on
the phone and then they have it ready to
go so if you just walk in and take it
I've done that once okay and I do feel
bad about it why do you do that just for
The Rush no because I really didn't have
that much money so I was like [ __ ] it I
don't want to make anything so I stole a
salad and you put yours because I feel
bad about it saying it out loud wait
you're but you're at the whim of
whatever that person ordered no I call
it and their systems yeah and so and
it's with the postmate orders so a lot
of times people just come get their [ __ ]
and leave and it's already paid for
right but the salad was not paid for but
I just went in and took it like it was
paid for she called they processed it
like a seamless order yeah I got you put
it over there that's a little less
trashy than just going in and grab
somebody else's order that you don't
know what they like on their salad yeah
no it could be like pickles and
mayonnaise or something that's actually
a good one though
what was the mayonnaise in the house
growing up was it Hellman's or was it
Miracle Whip or Dukes or whatever you
guys have out there wasn't it it wasn't
any of those it was best foods that's
yeah
okay as long as it wasn't Miracle Whip
no
um we had craft singles in the fridge
did you what color white or orange
orange not bad I didn't even know they
made white ones yeah I didn't know they
made orange ones for a long time
um
the bed you're in now queen size queen
how many pillows are on the bed
five and how many do you sleep with just
one under your head are you holding one
is one between your legs I sleep with
one pillow but if I tell you where I got
my bed from it'll probably make you
think I'm garbage
um damn uh I don't know what program
you've been watching
[ __ ] time share time over here
or you might have forgotten I'm inbred
but what uh where'd you get to bed from
um my friend who wasn't Ed Hardy
designer
okay yeah all right and Ed Hardy he was
he would drive like tigers and stuff on
the shirts have you ever worn Ed Hardy
yes in your Club in days yes on Dutch
hat or something yes ahead of on Dutch
hat so just one pillow behind your head
that's it yeah one pillow do you sleep
on your back or on your side
um my side all right do you have a duvet
cover yeah okay do you have a comforter
yeah does it have a cover around the
comforter yeah that's a duvet cover okay
what program are you watching I was
thinking of the things that go in the
bottom of the bed that's a bed skirt I
think our parents used to call that a
duvet yeah they did I just found that
out like a few months ago but to cover
the yeah we have I have a bed skirt
over the box spring uh if you sleep with
a fan on you yeah you do do you use your
phone as a alarm clock yes okay
all right what's the noise you wake up
to whatever the standard noises yeah
okay well do you have do you have a
ringtone now or you vibrate vibrate okay
um you're brushing your teeth in the
shower
I have but regularly I do it at the sink
and what's the toothbrush is it electric
or is it regular regular and do you pee
in the shower I have you have but not on
a regular basis
[Music]
I pee in the shower more than I'm
comfortable admitting out loud okay all
right it's a weird wet place to draw the
line and what you've already
I Made bread and I pee in the shower I
am what I am have you or anybody in your
family your friends anybody in your
circle ever gone dumpster diving
okay
there's a sale it's it's kind of close
to dumpster diving but it's not really
but there's a sale on Sundays at this
place called jet Rag and they have like
they take out huge boxes of vintage
clothes and everything's a dollar and
they throw it on the sidewalk and then I
dig through it
that's okay I'll give you that that's a
that's a that's a that's not dumpster
diving necessarily it's just the way
though it's designed um never smoke weed
out of a soda can yes in the last 15
years yeah last year no last five years
um not that I can remember but I
wouldn't be out of the realm when was
the last time you smoked out of an apple
do you sneak snacks into the movie
theater yes
oh okay if you had to pick one Fritos
Cheetos or Pringles
Pringles what's your favorite what kind
just the sour cream and onion it's
pretty classy good
that is the classiest answer out of all
of those 100 I think it's the classiest
thing she said
I have ever been an audience member at
anything what do you mean like
um Oprah or anything like that a live TV
live TV TV thank you no any family
members ever on uh the local news no
anybody family members Ever represent
themselves in court
I guess your dad's a lawyer okay ever
cut your own hair
my mom cut my own hair your mom cut your
hair back in the day okay on the regular
uh like if I needed a bang trim Debbie
would do it okay
that would be trimming these bags what's
the luggage situation these days what do
you got it's my parents I just take it
you just I borrow I'm borrow your
website
I'm renting my parents Sam's Insight
whatever
are you TSA pre-checked no but I'm clear
okay okay maybe that
um do you take your shoes off on the
plane yes really
depends on how long the flight is like
the New York flight I did because I was
like [ __ ] this I need to get comfy what
airline did you fly over JetBlue
was there a movie involved uh yeah
what'd you watch I watched some Alanis
Morissette uh documentary okay
do you remember how old you were the
first time you had Lobster
yeah probably a teenager okay that's not
bad do you have tattoos yeah have you
ever gotten a tattoo not in a tattoo
parlor yeah I did I got one at skank
Fest Houston it was so bad I had to get
it covered up oh really it's been
covered up yeah no it looked like a
holocaust tattoo for sure it was so bad
after your dad was thrilled yeah no my
parents were [ __ ] hated it so then
this year I had to get it covered up
before next year's none of these big
covering up the mistake from skank Fest
Houston
what was the tattoo pretty good though
it was my area code
it was an 818 area code 818 yep how
could that be that bad it's three three
numbers they [ __ ] it up yeah okay
because they made one of the eights like
a normal eight and then the other one
was a snowman eight like two circles on
top of each other okay it ended up
looking like two snowmen playing table
tennis by the time it was done it didn't
look like an A1A it was so [ __ ] ugly
okay
um and I also got a tattoo oh I forgot
about this as street fair
a street fair tattoo on my neck a bow
that your neck on the back of my neck
yeah Bo a street fair had a street fair
yeah in L.A how much was it I don't know
I didn't pay for it my friends were like
um if we get if we get if we find sixty
dollars for you to get this tattoo will
you get it and I said yes and then I got
it and it's above so sixty dollars bad
tattoo or good tattoo I'll let you be
the judge you wanna see it I'm scared
you want to see it yeah sure it's it's I
think it's somewhere in between it's not
bad or good
or good it's all right it's not terrible
it's not bad
it's got a little bit of writers Island
Vibes
a little sing-singy
it's a sickle and blood dripping off of
it yikes all right okay do you take
anything from the hotel you take the the
moisturizer the hair conditioner or
anything like that the TV right now in
the hotel it depends on the brand if
yeah at the Golden Nugget I said I think
I'm good here I'll just take your finest
times here please
I'll take a five-year contract if you
got it can you juggle
no do you own a Swiffer right now yes
you do yeah
okay that's pretty good uh are you
currently currently stocked in both the
wet and the dry Foods no for the for the
Swiffer the pads The Mask no I just have
the wet ones just the Wet Ones give a
pet now yes what do you have a dog you
have a doggy what kind of dog you got
he's uh he's a super mutt okay okay I
got one of those you do yeah yeah he's a
bunch of different things he's like
husky and an Australian Shepherd dog and
so it's a bigger dog he's a big dog yeah
does he get to sleep on the bed with you
yeah are you allowed to be on all the
furniture yeah does he shed everywhere
yeah
is there any dog hair on you right now
no okay because I don't believe it but
still no not now but maybe at some of my
clothes back of my hotel sure okay
do you roll with a lint roller if I feel
like it if I can find the lint roller oh
sure that's uh all the pillows on your
bed have a pillowcase on them yes any uh
male family members of your family
uncle's cousin's dad have a ponytail
oh but growing up my cousin did have a
rat tail that was the 90s
a lot of people made a lot of bad hair
decisions
um you have a complete set of towels in
your house or apartment now no you don't
no do you have any hand towels yes okay
one I have one hand towel one like one
proper one proper hand towel how often
do you have a washer and dryer in your
unit I have it yeah I have it right next
to me okay okay
but that doesn't usually make probably
every cycle I would assume the hand
towel yeah no but I'm pretty I'm pretty
good at my laundry situation okay
what kind of laundry detergent you're
using use this weird laundry I can't
think of what you gotta be like all
natural or so you got to go like Seventh
Generation I have sometimes Seventh
Generation but then I on a whim was
stoned and I bought this other kind by
the laundress off Amazon this [ __ ] was
nice yeah I'm running low I don't know
if I could buy it again
you know what's big that we just got my
wife bought they're like sheets they're
like dryer sheets uh-huh you put it it's
like just it's like
paper soap or something oh I know what
you're talking about yeah they're all
right I'm not I don't know
um
favorite fast food in the camping in and
out Taco Bell
I wouldn't expect anything less from you
so I don't think I would
um let's see you have magnets on the
fridge no no magnets no
shoes off when you go into the house
depends on my mood
how many people come over you don't say
you gotta take your shoes off no what
about growing up
growing up
I don't think we enforce that no
um really could you eat in your room as
a kid no no no not allowed to do that no
but now I eat my room now you eat in
your bedroom take that Mom yeah and
where do you eat most of your meals in
when you're at home on the couch in
front of the TV or in your room I like
any them in my bed you eat them in your
okay yeah you have a TV in your room yes
okay are you eating it laying down or
sitting at the end of the bed watching
TV lying down laying down okay what I'm
saying is I'm depressed
are you depressed I eat a lot laying
down
do you booze a lot no no what's your
go-to drink if you had to drink tequila
just straight up the Keel to kill soda
yeah tequila soda with a lime do you
have a tequila you prefer you know the
expensive kind so I don't feel that
hungover okay all right I'll give it to
you she's a straight shooter yeah
okay uh I think I mean I'm we're pretty
good here of course yeah we're just
having fun this is all just uh you know
have you ever um I just want to see how
deep this guy is
never been in a cruise no but would you
like to be
I kind of want to do one part of me
feels like it would be fun because for
185 right now if you got it on you if
you have it on you if you can pay cash
uh-huh uh if you're going out to a nice
meal at night will you not eat all day
yeah
absolutely
I prepare I get my money's worth yeah
when was the last time you smoked a
Black and Mild
never never okay
um
if you and your friends go out you
splitting the check yeah splitting the
check up yeah we are okay
we're dicing that [ __ ] up
hmm
interesting yeah
no juggling no juggling when was the
last time you had a Hibachi restaurant
not that long ago August why to August
because I went on it I went on the date
with this dude and he took me to a gun
range where I had a panic attack so then
we had to reroute figure something else
out of [ __ ] yell at me and eat at a
communal table okay yeah so then we went
to Hibachi restaurant because of mine
which is the highest of anxiety eating
you could possibly have there's Open
Flame and a man throwing stuff at you
the onion volcano I missed the shrimp
and I freaked out uh why'd you have a
panic attack of the gun range just
because of the obvious the guns and all
yeah the guns did you know that did you
know that's where he was taking you no
he surprised me what the [ __ ] he
surprised me by taking me the gun range
and on the way there he goes okay so you
wanna know where we're going I'm like
sure he goes the gun range and then I go
oh and I'm not sure I'm gonna like that
but oh if you want to do that he's like
no you'll be fine what are you talking
about you used to ride Bulls right yeah
different energy
huh okay
do you ever get uh do you ever ask for
anybody's autograph
when I tell you who's autograph it was I
coffee shop and at night there was a
singer that was singing there's some
random dude and I thought he was so good
I said I asked for his autograph
and then and then the characters at
Disneyland
really as a kid as a kid I'll give you
that okay
um have you ever been involved in a
pyramid scheme
I'm like I'm thinking about it and I I
want to say no but then also based on
the time share stuff yeah it's not that
far right yeah yeah yeah yeah ever had
your identity stolen yes really really
yeah take it into the accounts they some
they rented a U-Haul in my name
and then I got sent the bill I was like
I didn't rent a U-Haul what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah and I got robbed at a
Starbucks once and then they how like I
was just being a dumb [ __ ] hanging out
at the fountain with my purse like next
to me and they just grabbed your first
guy ran up grabbed my purse and then he
went to McDonald's and spent 80 dollars
damn it was 80 bucks was it Henry back
in China
that's an impressive bill of Mickey D's
have you ever skied in jeans have you
ever gone skiing no no not once no
surfing yes are you any good or no no I
did it when I was 14 I did adventure
camp because I had a crush on a dude
what's adventure camp well it's where
you go to the beach and they teach yeah
it's like here's an adventure how did it
work out with the kid I didn't did it
okay
he drowned during
the wakeboarding session can you speak
any other languages no I took I've taken
Spanish so many times I should know but
I I can't how'd you do on your SATs
really bad in math I think
the total score was really low I think
it was like a 10 20. that's good I mean
that's good out of 1600 yeah yeah that's
good that's good sir that is good yeah
she's shot oh really
let me ask you this that's not bad four
digit you're in the four digits bear
just barely all right uh do you cook at
the house at all yes you do yeah now do
you think it's acceptable to uh if
you're making spaghetti to make the
whole thing of pasta and you put the
whole jar of sauce or you just make half
of the Box
um I use all sauce use all the sauce we
make the whole box of pasta yeah
thank you you're not in good company
is there baking soda in your
refrigerator
yes in your freezer too no
have you ever had caviar
yes did you like it no no yeah I don't
think I've ever had it have you ever
been kicked out of a restaurant I've
been carried out of a bar
and that's why we love you
that's just a good time right there
I try to steal my ex-boyfriend's wall it
and I got carried out of the bar yeah
I've also been carried out of a bar too
on my day I have also done one thing
trashy I feel I feel like you guys
should know about I brought tuna into a
movie theater
you gotta
You Gotta Give a Cheesy cracker head
open as a babies maybe she's a little
facial was it a sandwich or in a bowl oh
Styrofoam cup did you make it at the
house no where'd you get where did you
get tuna fish I went to the we had
dinner next door to where the theater
was and I had leftover tuna so I was
like I'll just bring it to the movie
theater and I ate it and I remember my
ex-boyfriend looking at me like he was
gonna hit me he was like so not too
[ __ ] crazy crazy that's crazy not
tuna fish a Tunis like tuna salad
tuna salad yeah like like tuna salad
like Mayo eat tuna you want that for
dinner yeah
I mean that's crazy that's the craziest
thing I've ever heard he's going to
dinner and you get tuna ladies and
gentlemen Sarah wine shank thank you so
much 100 trash really yeah
112 but absolutely [ __ ] fantastic
that was amazing uh what do you got
coming up what do you want the folks out
there to know uh I'm gonna be at the
Brea Improv on December 21st with Kim
Kong headlining and then we're going to
be in Texas January 6th we're doing this
[ __ ] live from Vulcan and then we're
also co-headlining and then Arizona at
the end of January probably the time
share yeah yeah yeah well I scheduled a
show on the way back from the timeshare
all businesses
um and yeah just follow me at princess
shank Instagram and Twitter for more
dates I have a lot of La dates I don't
know them off top of my head but you'll
find them all online and then I have a
patreon.com Sarah winechaink and I put
ad-free content on there too very nice
unbelievable absolutely amazing guys go
see that show with her and Kim
absolutely fantastic Kippy what do you
got for him uh guys we have a couple of
tickets left in Boston couple tickets
left in Providence uh get those tickets
before they are gone they are last shows
for the year okay we love you we'll see
you next week peace